okay we're back on the Internet what
does the panel think of a President
Obama's announcement that he will try
again to address equal pay for women is
this a fool's errand in this Congress
isn't everything yes yes this is a
fool's errand it's not gonna happen they
just don't have the votes I mean that
his wholesale Union address was sort of
a laundry list of things he wants but
her I really gonna have it there's so
much talk about or there was the last
couple of months after the election
about well they're gonna find areas of
common ground what then what even if he
said he would do what they already said
they like as soon as he says he likes it
they say no then they don't like it
that's happened before yeah yeah yeah
black tracking we call it yeah maybe
maybe some compromise on tax reform
maybe on trade I mean he's got to
convince Democrats to get on board with
that but I mean it's sort of small-bore
stuff I actually have an exception
proving the rule the latest military
budget passed the Armed Services
Committee by 60120 that's something they
can agree on is that we always need to
rain death from above okay
uh-uh Brett what do you make of the
recent developments in Yemen yes
we've this week the president of Yemen
fell left the country rebels took over
are you confident in a barn Obama's
foreign policy yes and his approach to
dealing with this newest instability no
and what's terrifying is that back in
September
he cited Yemen as a success story of
American counterterrorism policy and he
should have seen the future you are so
rest because two weeks later the
government of Yemen effectively fell to
the people we call hang on a second all
right if you don't get the prediction
right two years out I understand if
you're the president and two weeks after
in a prime time address you say Yemen is
the way to go and then the hootie
militia
who are an arm or a proxy for the
Iranian government take over it's not
you're not being well informed by your
intelligence advisors to say just just
off the top of my head a couple of
examples Bush I looked in Putin's eyes
and he's a great guy
Bush Maliki he's our guy there in Iraq
right but we're talking about we're
talking about Obama and we're talking
about what's happening in yeah
I know I mean it's great to switch the
subject to Bush switching was epic it's
on the subject of presidents who made
predictions that were then wrong yes
that were instantly proved wrong after a
pro after a prime time address and
what's worrisome is that we now have in
Yemen and this is serious we now have in
Yemen a country that is divided between
an Iranian backed militia which which
now has control over the other half of
the Arabian Peninsula and al-qaida in
the Arabian Peninsula which helped trade
the killers in Paris so means that when
you create these uncovered spaces even
if you think you're pursuing a
successful counterterrorism model
you run the risk of having jihad pursue
you outside of a little unfair to blame
Obama since this thing's been called The
Empty Quarter for about two centuries
this has been a none governed space for
create you know
I mean really we Korea Obama created the
imma for that it was cool no what I'm
saying is that if the president is going
to go out of his way to cite Yemen as a
great Counter Terrorist success story
and it goes downhill very quickly it
behooves us to ask the president the
same tough questions you asked of george
w bush okay
what if anything will happen with Boko
Haram in Nigeria any chance for bold
international action yeah everybody
seems to have forgotten about the boys
from Boko one of this is a really sad
story because Nigeria actually used to
be have a strong army and be actually a
fairly strong country this is a
completely corrupt incompetent person
running Nigeria who has actually made no
effort whatsoever for his own political
reasons not to get rid of Boko Haram
it's a disaster and you don't call them
Islamic terrorists either
Boko Haram yeah I call them thugs and
horrible people
okay the New York Times said that there
are 5,000 in their words Islamic
militant groups we take out Islamic from
all 5,000 that's all just the
coincidence well look this is a tough
guy to argue with look I have to say
okay so bill listen I mean I feel better
I feel like I'm in high school again
where I'm just sitting there like I'm
not passing this class
there's no way you're gonna do worse
than me so I have had it so what all
confessed it was being a propagandist I
just think if you call an Islamic you're
doing what they want you to do so I
don't believe in doing what they want us
to do that's all yeah don't you think
that if you're I mean as a doctor as a
doctor don't you have the name of the
disease in order to yeah thank you
yes exactly a naming is everything and
that's why I like to call them thugs and
terrorists out of Islamic terrorists
that's kind of why so it's kind of like
Franklin Roosevelt in 1941 second my
fellow Americans we face a group of
militarists who take it over Germany
have nothing to do with the country of
Germany or the ideologies of nationalism
or socialism well come on even in the
gym yeah so so to weigh in on the
governor side for a couple of points so
there are 5,000 these groups they may
well be Islamically connected thugs that
you know there are a billion people in
the world who are largely peaceful
Muslims I lived in Indonesia and
Malaysia but we're not as nobody to know
but it is a straw man that we always
face in this argument that's but there's
connected to the other point there's a
really it's difficult in the news media
and politics to keep proportion on
disaster proportion on threats there was
this horrible horrible episode in France
where what 16 people were terribly
murdered and you say there's what
thousand hundred thousands in Nigeria
they're like page a 23 or something so I
think it's worth having proportion about
the threats proportion about having some
kind of consistent standard of our
outrage but should the consistency be
not to suddenly become cultural
relativist when it comes to what Boko
Haram does to girls in Nigeria would
have come when it comes to what Saudi
Arabia does sure religious minorities
when it comes to what Iran does to get
your stash or Pakistan I was in the
school on your house I don't have any
problem with condemning those people
great so I mean so what is the point
what is what is the culture a
relativistic about this but we use that
you know I see but the point is you're
pretending that this has nothing to do
with a civilization that is in crisis
not particularly and by the way if you
want if you want someone to attest to
this the president of Egypt went to all
our University which is the heart of
Islamic religious theology Sunni
theology and said we have to change so
it right he is someone who is not trying
to align the subject for the sake of
polite there is a point I'm nothing to
do it this is a crucial point if you've
lived outside the u.s. in these
countries you see that every time we
call them Islamic terrorists every time
an American president a British Prime
Minister does that it objectively
increases the sympathy in places in in
Indonesia in India it just is the case
and so when naming makes our task harder
we should be careful about the way we
get this is like a Harry Potter novel
and by the way you know there are a lot
of Muslims now who disagree with you too
who say this makes our job harder they
say you know we want someone to stick up
for our version of Islam but when when
you won't admit what the other version
is it makes it harder for us we need
those people to stand up and it's easier
to stand up if they can distance
themselves and what these people are
doing let's stop talking about all right
does the panel have faith in the outcome
of the nuclear talks with Iran should
Congress stay out of it I would say
Congress definitely stay out of it yes
sir yeah it's on it yes yes the thing I
was in DC just a day or two ago talking
with a bunch of European representatives
their great fear is the Congress through
posturing will make impossible something
is going to be difficult anyway so the
Congress you know they can just say
whatever they want they don't have to
try to make these deals so I pray to God
of whatever faith that the Congress
would stay out of this and let the
various governments my view is these
things are going to collapse anyway and
the Congress shouldn't do something
stupid and make it up make it more
likely why is it so objectionable to say
that if the third round not the first
the third round of negotiations well in
that event sanctions will kick in
because my words is in Kompany the deal
with foreign policy that regulation I
would have loved to have heard from that
in say 2006 2007 when the shoe was on
wanted a Democratic Congress and during
the George W Bush administration to
invite say the president of France to a
joint session of Congress to criticize
the president and discuss freedom fries
I wouldn't have questioned the right to
do it it's a coma music only wisdom of
doing it what is the wisdom really from
the Obama administration making such as
I'm talking politically what's the
wisdom of them making such a stink about
it
what if they let it pass without comet
nobody would nobody would notice instead
they've created a political crisis where
none need have existed what would you
have written in the Wall Street Journal
in 2006 a Democratic Congress invited
the French president to attack george w
bush Nancy Pelosi is the Speaker of the
House in 2007 could have done it okay I
know but my question but would there not
have been outrage especially by The Wall
Street Journal hum on don't you don't
please you can't look me in the eye and
tell me I'd be toke totally clue with if
they had invited save Vladimir Putin
after he had invited vada Georgia or
done something horrible yeah because he
would have been a bad guy to invite
their last I checked at least nominally
and notionally we all agree that Israel
is an ally of the United States and a
democratic ally and Prime Minister can
accept an invitation as a rental event
which was my question
right France is fine I like the friend
they're an ally but but no country no
matter how close they are to which
should be making American policy we're
getting very close on the Iran issue to
allowing Israel to write American policy
I'm sorry didn't David Cameron just come
to the United States and admit that he
was lobbying individual US senators on
the subject of Iran sanctions so if
you're gonna make that argument but two
can play the game I mean that's what
Cameron is doing on behalf of Obama okay
all right thank you very much bill has
to get to his tutor
sweet thank you very much